[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la nuit dernière qui en terro a été
impliqué dans une rixe
il touche 3 millions d'euros par
j'aimerais que tu réalises que si on
fait de si gros chèque c'est beau que tu
t'entraînes et tu joue au ballon ça la
vedette fait la une de tous les journaux
mais toujours pour des conneries tu peux
rester devant ta télé dimanche je vois
pas
vous voulez faire étudier ce footballeur
pour les faire passer son bac
un sac aussi vous voyez tu t'appelles tu
vraiment sérieusement vous n'avez aucune
idée de caisse comme ceux du cheval fou
de toi et tu dis à nico d'annuler les
rendez vous sur mes oreilles on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps
allez tout une touche toi
on avoue ça toute la journée je suis
débile
le voilà le problème
[Musique]
en fait j'ai fait une erreur de méthode
la première guerre mondiale à ce stade
là que fait l'allemagne
elle n'est pas contente oui elle est pas
contente c'est la première fois que je
reprends goût à mon travail
pour que je suis pas devenu fou
je voudrais te revoir
en fait personne n'a rien à [ __ ] de ce
cos de quoi t'as pas de me retrouver
seule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]